so we will get AI without understanding
how it works and there were people
saying like well we will have giant
neural networks that we will Train by
gradient descent and when they are as
large as the human brain they will wake
up we will have intelligence without
understanding how intelligence works and
from my perspective this is all like an
indistinguishable lob of people who are
trying to not get to grips with the
difficult problem of understanding how
intelligence actually works
that said
I was never skeptical that evolutionary
computation
would not work in the limit like you
throw enough computing power at it it
obviously works
that is where humans come from
and it turned out that you can throw
less computing power than that at
gradient descent
if you are doing some other things
correctly
and you will get intelligence without
having any idea of how it works and what
is going on inside
um it wasn't ruled out by my model that
this could happen I wasn't expecting it
to happen I wouldn't have been able to
call neural networks rather than any of
the other paradigms for getting like
massive amount like intelligence without
understanding it
and I wouldn't have said that this was a
particularly smart thing for a species
to do this week there was an open letter
calling for AI labs to pause the
development of AI systems which are more
powerful than gpt4 for at least six
months
1537 signatures have been collected to
address what they say is the profound
risks of AI systems and the risks that
they pose to society and Humanity
the letter emphasizes the importance of
carefully planning and managing Advanced
AI systems and expressed concern about
the lack of control over increasingly
powerful AI models it urged AI labs to
focus on making existing AI systems
safer and more transparent and
trustworthy while also working with
policy makers to create robust AI
governance systems the call for a pause
purportedly aimed to ensure what they
say would be a flourishing future with
AI allowing Society to adapt and enjoy
the benefits of the technology a cynical
reading of this is oh it's just AGI
doomers or it's folks who have a vested
interest in open AI not being successful
in a way it's a shame that the first two
options take away the attention on the
real societal impacts of AI but there's
a problem with this approach first of
all Global competition with countries
like the US and China Investing heavily
in AI research and development no single
nation would fall behind in this
technological race implementing a
moratorium would only hinder progress in
countries that comply While others
continue to advance their AI
capabilities
Unstoppable progress the development of
AI is becoming increasingly accessible
and affordable making it nearly
impossible to Halt its advancement
completely even if major corporations
and governments agreed to a moratorium
individuals and smaller organizations
could still continue to work on AI
projects also the potential benefits AI
has the potential to revolutionize
various industries from Healthcare to
transportation and could help address
some of the world's most pressing
problems such as climate change and
poverty by imposing a moratorium on AI
we risk losing out on these potential
benefits and slowing down progress in
key areas and also managing risks
instead of avoiding them rather than
trying to Halt AI development entirely
it would be more productive to focus on
understanding mitigating and managing
the risks associated with AI and this
could include developing AI safety
measures ethical guidelines and
Regulatory Frameworks that help ensure
responsible development and deployment
of AI systems the real problem is that
there's no friction between the legal
landscape and the technology landscape
at the moment like if if you already
have giant nuclear stockpiles don't
build more if some other country starts
building a larger nuclear stockpile than
sure build then you know
even then maybe just have enough nukes
you know there's the these things are
not quite like nuclear weapons they spit
out gold until they get large enough and
then ignite the atmosphere and kill
everybody
um
and there is something to be said for
not destroying the world with your own
hands even if you can't stop somebody
else from doing it
but but open sourcing it now that that's
just sheer catastrophe oh the whole
notion of open sourcing this was always
the wrong approach the wrong ideal there
are there are places in the world where
open source is a noble ideal and
building stuff you don't understand that
is difficult to control that where if
you could align it it would take time
you'd have to spend a bunch of time
doing it that is that is not a place for
open source because then you just have
like powerful things that just like go
straight out the gate without anybody
having had the time to have them not
kill everyone
yep yep it's um it's very true this is a
this is another classic and the
alignment world is that uh it's kind of
like futurist whack-a-mole where the
usual way this game this this happens is
uh the futurist says um hey I think you
know AGI you know do some like crazy
things and like things we can't
understand or predict and then the
interlocutor will be like well okay name
one thing and then they name a thing and
like oh no that's actually irrelevant
because actually that can be fixed using
this and then and then like well yeah
sure but what about you know scenario
two and like oh okay yeah but like we
could have done this other thing to
solve that but then and then the future
is some points like don't you see the
problem you didn't think of one or two
before I pointed out to you yeah but I
could fix it once you pointed out like
no no the generalized form of this is
that a sufficiently intelligent system
will come up with even more things than
neither you nor me can come up with this
is a it's very funny how often I've run
into this exact scenario where I I like
give people us like people ask me for a
scenario and I'm like fine here's the
scenario and they're like oh okay well
I'm not worried anymore because I could
fix that one and then they don't
generalize to the general case like okay
but you didn't come up with it either so
what are all the other things you're not
coming up with if you're dealing with a
system that is smarter than you you
should just expect it can trick you even
if you can't come up with how it can
trick you you should just assume there
is something you can do that can drink
you we should worry though about people
using large language models to control
things like electrical power grids there
are companies now who want to make
current AI which is limited in a bunch
of ways and connected to every bit of
the world software that seems like a
scary mission to me not because these
systems are going to go Rogue and
deliberately want to take over the world
because they don't understand the world
and so they're going to make bad
decisions when the world is different
from how it was when they were trained
decision theorist elieza udkowski just
published an article in Time Magazine
calling for an indefinite and worldwide
moratorium on the development of
artificial general intelligence boldly
asserting that we're not ready for the
potential catastrophe it may bring
yukowski argued that the key issue is
not human competitive intelligence but
rather the consequences of creating an
AI which exceeds human intelligence he
warns that if we continue on our current
path we risk creating an AI that doesn't
care for us or sentient life and may
lead to the extinction of humanity
yukowski emphasizes that in his opinion
the situation is dire and a mere
six-month moratorium is insufficient he
urges for an immediate halt to all AI
large training runs and the shutdown of
major GPU clusters with no exceptions
for governments or militaries he calls
for international cooperation to enforce
these measures stressing that we all
live or die as one in this matter so in
this passionate plea yudkowski argued
that policy makers should recognize the
gravity of the situation and take
decisive action to shut it all down he
contends that if we Forge ahead
recklessly everyone including innocent
children will suffer the consequences
for it
the thing is though
this just doesn't really add up does it
I mean first of all the hard limits on
AGI I mean one counter argument is that
there are hard limits in what any AGI
can do
um you know it can't break encryption it
can't invent warp drives it can't cure
Alzheimer's and critics argue that
yukowski's fear of AGI bootstrapping
itself into the real world by emailing a
DNA sequence to a synthesis company it
seems patently absurd as if an AGI is
not an intellectual Santa Claus machine
the comparison of the 11th century
fighting the 21st century is also
perceived as inaccurate as the 11th
century people were not Dumber they just
knew less an AGI would be smarter but
doesn't know more than we do
critics also argue that the extinction
risk discussions are unmoored from
various fields of knowledge including
evolutionary biology cognitive
psychology real AI sociology and indeed
the history of Technology the arguments
lack a plausible sequence of events with
logical causality that lead to mass
extinction and instead rely on hand wavy
assumptions and hypotheticals some
believe that the real threat to humanity
is nuclear war and yutkowski's
suggestion to bomb Rogue Data Centers
may actually be more dangerous than any
AI development
also there's a concern that even if some
researchers and organizations were to
Halt their AI development others would
continue creating a collective action
problem stopping AI development is seen
as impossible as no one's willing to
give up when someone else out there is
willing to take the risk for the
potential Advantage this reality calls
for a different approach such as
focusing on defensive AI even though it
might be futile and also there's this
thing about a misplaced focus on AI in
particular some argue that Humanity has
more pressing concerns such as the
oceans are dying plastic pollution
increasing inequality the rise of
authoritarianism and nuclear
proliferation this focus on creating
apocalyptic Doom AGI it may just be
misplaced the universe should be full of
Berserkers if that was a likely outcome
critics question why is super
intelligent AI trained on the collective
data of humanity would even want to
destroy Humanity instead of coexisting
or even emulates us
so in conclusion elieza's call for an
indefinite and worldwide moratorium on
AI development has generated a lot of
lively debate with many questioning the
plausibility of his concerns and
offering different perspectives but
while the potential risks of AI can't be
ignored it's essential to consider
various arguments and potential
Solutions before making such a drastic
decision to be able to make it look so
authoritative at essentially no cost in
such a volume it's like the difference
between retail and wholesalers like you
know the difference between a knife and
a sub machine gun I mean you can do harm
with a knife but you can do a lot more
harm with a submachine gun and so
um I am you know American citizen I'm
really really concerned about the 2024
elections and how this is going to play
out
um and these things can move really fast
now so give you a related example
um the science fiction magazine I think
might actually be British called Clark's
world and they have open submission so
anybody can submit a story which is a
great thing from a social perspective
because we would like you know to have
new writers discovered and not just have
old boys networks and that kind of stuff
and like a month ago Chachi PT or maybe
it's two months ago let's say chat GPT
came out at that point they were getting
no fake stories and then they got like
one or two and they're like ah this is
interesting and then they got like seven
the next day and then like within a week
or a month or something like that they
got like 600 a day and they actually had
to shut down they couldn't do the open
submissions anymore because it was so
much computer generated garbage I don't
think any of those stories were good but
they all took humans time to deal with
and it's going to be like that with
misinformation we may be able to build
new technologies to address it but we
don't have anything now off the shelf
that works all that well if we in one
shot build systems that are so far
beyond cognitive Horizon we can't
understand them and then we turned them
on we die
obviously if we
can we build systems that are 0.5 or 1.5
on the horizons and we just develop much
much better theories to understand them
now that's more that's a more
interesting question and if we have a
1.5 system can we use it to build a 2.5
system and if we have a 2.5 system can
we use that to build a five system and
if you have a five system can you
understand a 10 system I don't have an
answer to this question but it doesn't
seem obviously impossible to me it seems
obviously probably impossible that if
you just get a thousand X AGI draws from
the sky you're screwed you can't
understand this thing it's you will
never understand this thing we will
never ever understand this thing and if
we turn it on that's it and game over
but if we build a much more that's why
that's why I'm focusing on this like we
get to build the AI
this is so this is a common conversation
to have with people where people are
like wow Conor why aren't you like happy
about like scaling laws it makes like
our Intel like predictable I'm like no
no it doesn't at all it's it's we don't
know how to predict how smart AIS are
this is a big problem while the Align
problem is hard is people sometimes will
be like oh it's fine we'll just wait
until it's like just below danger and
then we'll stop and I'm like first of
all LOL imagined corporations just
stopping and B how do you know you're
just one step away from the bad thing
before it's already too late how would
you know and sometimes people like you
know hand waves something's almost alien
loss I'm like okay at which loss does it
become super intelligent
and please show me the number like no of
course not that's very silly it's the
ability to predict how
powerful system will be is dependent not
only on the agent you're studying but
also on its environment so you also have
to have a very very strong theory about
the environment interacting with and
because the environment is the universe
and we don't have super strong
predictive theories of the entire
universe we can't predict this kind of
stuff and this is why this is at the
core of why I think this is hard
I think if we could all agree to just
like
I slow the down let's just like go
only like teeny micro steps until we've
like developed as much Theory as humanly
possible and then we take one more micro
step and then we develop as much Theory
as humanly possible and we take one more
micro step yeah I think we'd be fine
probably maybe not you know maybe one of
those microsteps still kills us but it's
like possible but like currently we're
not even trying like currently we're
just like let's just make as big a steps
as possible as often and as fast as
possible and just see what happens a
little
as AI continues to advance it's crucial
for researchers policy makers and
society as a whole to engage in an open
and Frank discussion about the potential
consequences and the best path forward
with a balanced approach to AGI
development we can be able to harness
its power for the betterment of humanity
while mitigating the risks it may pose
thank you